stimmt das alles überhaupt das ist jetzt
eine der wichtigsten Fragen die wir uns
und all unsere Reporter sich sowieso
jeden Tag stellen stimmt das überhaupt
diese Frage wird immer wichtiger jetzt
auch im Fall der Wilden 13 diese 13
Kegelfreunde aus Münster nach Mallorca
geflogen um mal richtig die Sau
rauszulassen und gelandet im Knast im
Suff eine ganze Bar abgefackelt damit
auf Mallorca Existenzen zerstört
leichtfertig und fahrlässig oder oder
war doch alles ganz ganz anders
von Ihrem Hotel Balkon sollen die
deutschen Kegelfreunde betrunken
Kippenstummel auf das Schilfdach der
benachbarten Bar why not geworfen haben
sogar Alkohol sollen sie noch hinterher
gegossen haben das Dach fängt Feuer
steht in wenigen Minuten in Flammen und
brennt lichterloh die Bar und das
darunter gelegene Bordell sind in nur
wenigen Minuten komplett ausgebrannt was
bleibt eine Ruine für die spanische
Justiz scheint klar schuld sind die
Kegelbrüder doch jetzt die spektakuläre
Wende war etwa alles anders sitzen die
13 Männer zu Unrecht im Knast
Rückblick bereits drei Tage nach dem
verheerenden Brand trifft Bild dem
Besitzer des Bordells silverio Mendo
mein ganzes Lokal war bereit für die
Saison wir wollten am Samstag eröffnen
jetzt steht alles durch das Löschwasser
beim Brand unter Wasser wir werden jetzt
erstmal nicht öffnen können mit diesem
Lokal habe ich meine Familie ernährt
jetzt weiß ich nicht wie es weitergehen
soll Bild erfährt die why not Bar und
das Bordell waren bis zum Brand noch
keinen einzigen Tag geöffnet Corona und
die Wintersaison verhinderten die
Inbetriebnahme anwohner berichten uns
dass der Zustand der Bar unfassbar
schlecht sein soll ein erfolgreiches
Establishment mit entsprechendem Umsatz
unwahrscheinlich
der geplante Tag der Neueröffnung
ausgerechnet am Tag des verheerenden
Brands auch feuerprofessor Roland Görtz
zweifelt daran dass Kippenstummel das
Feuer entfachten
mit dem bisher vorliegenden
Informationen scheint es mir zweifelhaft
das allein nur Zigaretten die
Brandursache waren Schilfrohr ist direkt
nicht gut entzündbar da es Kieselsäure
enthält
[Musik]
ein tragischer Zufall oder war es
Versicherungsbetrug mit Brandstiftung
doch nicht nur die Umstände der Bar und
die Expertenmeinung können die Vorwürfe
der spanischen Justiz entkräften vom
Eckbalkon des Hotels also gegenüber des
brennenden Dachs sollen die Jungs das
Feuer entfacht haben doch die 13
deutschen Freunde lebten nicht in diesem
Zimmer wir treffen eine Augenzeuge Maria
erlebte den ballermann-brand vor Ort
wählte sogar den Notruf zu Bild sagte
sie kurz nach dem Vorfall sie habe Jungs
beim Feiern und zigarettenschnipsen
beobachtet
[Musik]
ich habe gesehen wie junge Männer auf
dem Balkon standen und gefeiert haben es
wurde laute Musik gespielt plötzlich
stand die Terrasse in Flammen
jetzt konfrontiert Bild Maria erneut
zeigt ihr ein Foto der 13 Kegelbrüder
ich habe ihre Gesichter nicht richtig
gesehen hier kommt davon keiner
bekannta no no no no Serie maria ist
sich nun sicher die Deutschen die durch
ihre Lautstärke unangenehm aufgefallen
sind wohnten nicht in diesem Zimmer mit
Eckbalkon von dem das Feuer ausgegangen
sein soll
die Jungs standen nicht auf dem Balkon
ganz außen sondern auf der zweiten und
dritten Etage mittig wenn man von
Rechtsaußen anfängt zu zählen war es der
dritte Balkon und der Balkon darüber in
der dritten Etage Marias Aussage deckt
sich auch mit der der Verteidigung und
Familie die 13 kegelf lebten nicht in
dem Eckzimmer des Hotels ihr Zimmer
befand sich zehn Meter vom Ausbruch des
Feuers entfernt auch dieses Video
widerspricht den Aussagen der spanischen
Justiz zwei Männer auf dem Eckbalkon
während das Feuer lichterloh brennt zwei
Männer die nicht eindeutig den
Kegelbrüdern zuzuordnen sind kein
markant blaues T-Shirt wie sie es auf
ihrem letzten gemeinsamen Gruppenfoto
tragen auch Väter der Kegelfreunde sagen
Bild das sind nicht unsere Jungs die
Kegelfreunde wohnten also nicht in dem
Eckzimmer ihre vermeintlich
heruntergeworfenen Zigarettenstummel
müssten insofern Meter weit und um die
Ecke fliegen um das Feuer zu entfachen
geht das
seit einer Woche sitzen die Freunde
jetzt im malleknast 13 Männer unter
Generalverdacht handfeste Beweise
bislang unbekannt
möchten die mallorquinischen Behörden
hier ein Exempel statuieren ein
abschreckendes Beispiel um den
sauftourismus am Ballermann zu stoppen
damit bilder wie diese nicht mehr um die
Welt gehen 13 unschuldige Männer für
einen Imagewechsel die mallorquinischen
Behörden ermitteln weiterhin um den
Tathergang des 20 Mai nachzuvollziehen
bis dahin bleiben die Kegelfreunde in
Untersuchungshaft eingesperrt ohne
Chance auf Kaution 13 deutsche Freunde
im malleknast unschuldig
ja und das eben seit jetzt fast einer
Woche und weiter wühlt dort recherchiert
dort unser Bildreporter Jörg völkerling
auf Mallorca grüße Dich Jörg bei BILD am
Abend du konntest wir haben das gerade
schon gesehen mit den Papas mit den
Vätern sprechen dieser Kegel Jungs was
könnt ihr dir über den Ablauf dieses
Jahr schwierigen abends sagen
ja die waren zunächst am gestrigen Tag
noch etwas zurückhaltend ihre
Informationen mit der Öffentlichkeit zu
teilen weil sie wollten auf guten Willen
mit der Staatsanwaltschaft
zusammenarbeiten und hofften dass sich
das vielleicht doch noch auf dem kurzen
Dienstweg lösen lässt dass sie sich
schnell überzeugen aber dann sahen auch
die Verwandten im Münsterland dieses
Video von den zwei Jungs auf dem
Eckbalkon bei Bild TV und er sagten dann
auch spontan das sind doch nicht unsere
Jungs und so drangen heute im Laufe des
Tages immer mehr Details aus diesem von
diesen vergangenen Freitag
ans Licht also im Prinzip die Zeit wo
wir jetzt stehen war vergangenen Freitag
hier alles mit Feuerwehr voll und in der
Lobby hinter mir vom Hotel Wala Beach da
sind die 13 und wurden nacheinander von
der Guardia Civil abgeführt und es ist
schon sehr interessant die Aussage von
der Verkäuferin Maria die wohnt hat
ihren Supermarkt hier auf dieser Seite
hinter mir und die guckte nach oben und
zeigte uns
genau diese drei Balkone wo die
deutschen gefeiert hätten die dann
später auch der Anwalt Raban Funk uns
genannt hat wo sie sich eingemietet
hatten und ja und die Eltern haben uns
auch geschrieben dass die Jungs zum
Zigarettenrauchen dass sie Wassergläser
benutzen zum Beispiel bei mir halt
gefüllt mit Wasser um ihre kippen da
hinein zu tun also auch das sind so
Fakten die jetzt absolut sich nicht
vereinbaren lassen mit dieser Version
der Staatsanwaltschaft Jörg wann haben
die Eltern denn zuletzt mit ihren
Kindern dort mit den Kegeln Freunden
gesprochen wann ist die Kommunikation
abgerissen
es gab über den ganzen Freitagnachmittag
eine sehr intensive Kommunikation der 13
mit ihren Freundinnen zu Hause mit ihren
Familien die natürlich wissen wollten
wie geht es Euch und dann kam
tröpfchenweise Informationen ja unsere
Hotel fackelt gerade ab und dann gegen
Abend gegen 18:30 bis 20 Uhr wurden dann
nacheinander die Handys eingesammelt
dieser 13 und dann verschwanden sie
erstmal in denen man möchte fast sagen
Fängen der spanischen Justiz über einen
Anwalt den die Eltern einschalteten
erfuhren sie dann dass sie am Samstag
dem Haftrichter vorgeführt wurden waren
und ohne kautionsmöglichkeiten
Untersuchungshaft genommen wurden waren
erst am Sonntag gab es dann die ersten
Telefonate nach Deutschland und auch
jetzt ist die Möglichkeit Kontakt
aufzunehmen sehr beschränkt alle 13
zusammen haben ein Kontingent von 20
Minuten Telefongespräche am Tag heute
sollten die ersten persönlichen Besucher
möglich sein weil die 13 eben erst mal
eine Woche lang in Quarantäne genommen
worden sind und dass die Eltern sie
jetzt aber irgendwie wieder mit nach
Hause nehmen können in kürz Ester Zeit
daran ist an diesem Tag überhaupt nicht
zu denken